you know when my friend got out he was
in special ops and and uh not only was
he special ops he was also a delta unit
for eight years same as you and he went
all over and
my orders at the time was to go to
vicenza italy i was going to go to seer
school
i was already aristotle i was going to
airborne i was going to go dli to
tighten up my language because i spoke
five languages at the time
and i was going to go vicenza and then
from there you know light it up and
eventually going to you know choose to
go delta i went a different direction he
chose that route he took the orders he
went in
when he retired after 20 years i said
let's meet up we hadn't seen each other
for like 15 years i thought he was dead
quite frankly i was trying to find him
everywhere i couldn't find him anywhere
not on facebook not on social nowhere he
appeared out of nowhere on social we got
connected and this is my guy this is the
guy that you hung out with every day for
two and a half years so
i said let's meet up so we meet up in
madrid
let's go watch you know we'll go to el
clasico
ronaldo was playing messi i said let's
meet up in madrid he didn't come to the
game but he met me at madrid
i said how you doing
and uh uh
very traumatic this guy wasn't this kind
of a traumatic guy he was a fun guy to
be around he was not in a good place
at all for what i said what happened
what have you seen can't talk about it
he had a drink then he had a second
drink three drinks he still wouldn't
talk about it some of the stuff that he
had seen but he was very very emotional
he would call me regularly saying pat
i don't know how to deal with this stuff
right now took about a couple years for
him to disconnect from that life how
long did it take you after your 23 year
stint that you had to live a normal life
i know you're still married i think
right 20 plus years you guys have been
married yes it's pretty crazy to know
that you live that life and you're still
married for 20 plus years how long did
it take you after that life to actually
accept the civilian life
three years that i realized i don't have
to have my my bags packed and watching
the news
three years
three years of me not having to watch
current events and and and worry about
me
being deployed um
six years
before i found calmness of the mind six
years do you ever uh uh itch
the desire you know how athletes retire
they want to go back you know how the
movie hurt locker he got out he couldn't
wait to get back he these stories was
like chris kyle i got to get back man i
don't feel like the civilian life is for
me and the wife is trying to tell you
listen relax let's enjoy
let's have a life together do you have
that itch like dude i want to go to this
freaking place because i know i can
bring some value is that itch there to
want to get deployed and get into the
mixer no
i always want to help people
and i i guess that's why path is a ronin
now as i i help people
um my time overseas helping people
staying in villages and all that i just
can't physically do that anymore
you know but i always want to help
people
um was it hard let go of the gun fights
and all the adrenaline is
is very um
there's no drug out there
like the adrenaline like that at that
level of a gunfight right so people have
a hard time disconnecting
um for me i worked hard um after my uh
my time of service to disconnect and i
do it through meditation and everything
else so i i purposely
um walk down a path of peace
you know when i got out not a lot of
people do that no no especially not in
your world because it's typically uh
drugs alcohol
you know some crazy [ __ ] that they end
up doing when they when they've seen
that kind of life because as much as
you're glad you're out
somehow your body's that's your norm
that's your normal life that you've had
so it's very hard to adjust from that
pacing to
this thing being this slow it's going to
drive you insane most people it's going
to drive them yeah you know it's real
funny patrick when i got out i i went
into the entertainment kind of world
really they found me really fast because
you know i'm a knife i'm martial artist
i'm a gunfighter so it appeals to
hollywood you know so they they reached
out to me they wanted me to be on shows
on call of duty now so it's really like
uh a different mindset now
you know i mean i have to let it go
sometimes
you know like sometimes for you when i
walk in i'm like okay this is a pool
door it's a solid corridor this is my
extra rail this is how many piece
i had to let those things go
are you able to take orders from people
that are not you know i mean imagine
taking a direction from somebody that's
like you know 35 years old 120 pounds
and they're they're telling you what to
do and you're just sitting there like
man i could i could take your eyeballs
with my pinky no i don't think that
would i don't think that when you look
at people he's asking it because he's
struggling
he wants to yeah that's not how much
that's not how my brain works you know
guys how my brain works how my brain
works it's 4 30 in the morning i'm i'm
embracing god i'm showing gratitude to
life
and today like that's that's who i am
today you're like you know i never
wanted that to be that violent you know
in my career i did it for compassion i
did it to freedom enslaved
and as soon as that was over for me
what's my next purpose my next purpose
is to mold americans to to you know law
enforcement is having a hard time right
now
you know with their image and their
tactics and
and that's why i'm teaching i'm teaching
law-abiding citizens to protect
themselves you know across america
so along with that that i had to let go
of that hate
you can't be who you are if you hold on
to hate right i don't think it's about
holding on to hate i think it's maybe
more addiction to power
when you're talking about guys that come
out and they're getting violent it's
because they can because somebody tells
them something that they don't want to
hear and they're like you don't get to
tell me you're not you don't outrake me
i'm going to show you
20 years of imposing your will on other
people you don't just get to turn that
off no and you know like i say three
years you know i was i was talking one
of my friends is you know when you're in
the special forces when i kick open that
door when i come in
i have
you're going to feel an energy
right so i don't want that energy when i
live in civilian life right so i i have
to cut it off
and a lot of guys can't cut it off so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]